hey 42 here if you're watching this
video there's a one and three chance
you're on the toilet a one and three
chance you're already reading the
comments and a onein free chance that
you're eating something and if you are
eating there's a onein free chance that
bees played a part in producing it in
fact bees are responsible for
pollinating about 70% of all crops
globally and a third of all food
consumed by
humans but if you're picturing vast
commercial beef Farms you're a little
off Target most of the world's bees live
in small unassuming hives that dot the
countryside seemingly at random but make
no mistake these tiny colonies are the
invisible laborers keeping the world
fed you see pollination the process by
which plants reproduce is a delicate
business that requires a highly
specialized and very precise pollinator
for many plants that happens to be
bees basically bees help help plants to
have sex they transfer pollen from the
male parts of a flower to the female
parts so it can produce seeds and
fruit some plants are self-pollinating
and some are wind-pollinated but a
sizable number aren't without bees the
world would starve bee pollination is so
valuable the US government has a number
for it $15
billion that's the amount of money the
US economy would lose every year if bees
suddenly disappeared and that's just the
US globally bee pollination is worth at
least 150 billion doar a
[Music]
year however Behind These staggering
numbers is a staggeringly sad truth the
bees are disappearing and at an alarming
rate it's been called colony collapse
disorder it sounds like a heavy metal
band but it's actually a distressing
phenomenon first noticed in 20 6 each
year beekeepers are reporting losses of
roughly 30 to 45% of their colonies and
bees all over the world are now living
half as long as they did 50 years ago
and since our food chain would go the
way of Enron if bees stopped buzzing it
appears that the future of the human
race hinges on their
survival so that opens up two primary
questions what's actually causing the
precipitous decline of bees and what can
we do to stop it and I'm not going to
answer that first question because I
can't no one can yet we still don't
fully understand colony collapse
disorder scientists have some ideas but
it remains an unsolved mystery like why
Game of Thrones series eight was so
those ideas include climate change
pesticide usage and the proliferation of
Might particularly the aptly named Vora
Destructor which infests hives and feeds
on B Pupi
now you probably noticed that climate
change is messing up the timing of the
seasons and that's a problem because
many bees are very picky eaters and
they'll only feed on certain flowers
that bloom at specific times of the year
if the bees wake up from their winter
Slumber and find there's no pollen to be
had they'll die it's as simple as that
it's like walking home after a night out
to find the only cab shop in town is
closed you're going to do the only thing
possible sit on the pavement and die
pesticides are also a big problem in
2013 the European Union introduced a
temporary ban on the use of neon aoid
after they were found to be harming bees
since then the ban has been made
permanent and many other countries have
followed
suit so the bees are dying and we still
aren't completely sure why what do we do
well Humanity has a storied history of
creating new technologies to get
ourselves out of a pickle when our
cities grew too large started to smell
like shite we invented sanitation and
sewer
systems when population growth outpaced
farming we invented mechanized farming
to meet the demand and when everyone's
limbs turned green and fell off we
discovered
penicillin and now we might need to pull
yet another tech Miracle out of
Humanity's Last Chance Locker I think we
can all agree that the ideal solution to
B decline is to reverse the trend but
let's just imagine that we fail in this
Noble Endeavor in a last ditch attempt
to save our species couldn't we simply
replace all the bees with robot
bees surf shark VPN keeps you safe and
private by covering up everything you do
online and Sur shark VPN lets you travel
the world virtually by changing your
virtual location or whilst you are
physically traveling surf shark also
lets you connect via your home country
so you don't miss out on all your home
Comforts such as streaming video content
from home that might be blocked whilst
you're traveling no matter where I am in
the world I always use surf shark to
watch my favorite content from back home
there are over 3,200 servers in 100
countries so anywhere you go you'll find
a server that fits your needs s shock
VPN offers a multihop feature so you can
put two VPN servers between you and your
online destination for even more privacy
and security and personally I love Sur
shark's IP rotator featur
which constantly changes your device's
IP address without losing your VPN
connection it's so important to stay
safe online when you're out an about and
that's why I use surf shark VPN so I can
for example access my online banking
safely even on public Wi-Fi there's not
a chance I would ever do that without a
VPN vpn's also keep your location and
download history private so you can send
and receive files securely get an
exclusive Black Friday deal enter promo
code 42 to get up to six addition mons
for free at Sur shark. deals
sl42 don't miss out and a big thanks to
Sur shark for sponsoring this video as
you can imagine creating an autonomous
pseudo intelligence drone the size of a
bee that seeks out flowers and forces
them to have sex throws up countless
challenges Evolution has enjoyed a 3.5
billion year head start on us when it
comes to developing the perfect
pollinator we on the other hand only
started having a serious crack at it in
2009 so it's fair to say we have some
catching up to do growing up in the 21st
century you'll have no doubt witnessed
Humanity's struggle when it comes to
creating robots that can effortlessly
replicate the physical dynamics of
humans and other animals it's been
difficult enough trying to build a robot
that doesn't walk like it's pissed let
alone one that can convincingly shagger
Rose and it's not like we haven't been
trying either the Japanese have made
countless attempts at building a
lifelike sex robot sorry I meant to say
personal assistant and the Americans
have spent billions on robotic doggos
that will probably enslave
Humanity so it should come as no
surprise that trying to replicate bee
Dynamics in a mechanical vehicle is
really bloody difficult in case you
didn't know bees are the flying aces of
the animal world they can hover fly
backwards turn 90° almost
instantaneously and can even fly in the
rain despite weighing 100 millon
if that doesn't impress you just
remember that the average human male
can't even piss straight yet with over
two decades of R&D by the world's
brightest mines is still proving
difficult to replicate a bee's complex
Maneuvers and then there's the massive
issue of miniaturization it's taken us
half a century to go from room-sized
computers to the smartphone that's
beside you right now most honeybees and
bumblebees the most likely pollinators
are about 1 to 2 cm in length to pack
the sensors actuators computer chips
radio transmitters and batteries a
robotic B would require into such a tiny
form factor given the typical dimensions
of currently available components is
well it's like trying to fit a Boeing
747 into a hamster's
ass but all this hasn't stopped some
from trying building robotic bees that
is not improbable hamster insertions
most notably the robo project at Harvard
University has been at the Forefront of
this ambitious Endeavor with a wingspan
of just 3 cm the robo is a Marvel of
microbotics the robo be project was not
just about mimicking the flight of bees
but was also a general exploration of
microscale
engineering traditional methods of
building robots which involve rotary
Motors gears and nuts and bolts were
rendered obsolete at this scale instead
the team at Harvard had to innovate from
scratch developing a novel popup
assembly process this method inspired by
the Simplicity and precision of popup
books means the robo B can be printed as
a thin multi-layered sheet of carbon
brass and titanium then simply popped up
to create a 3D robot literally in
seconds the wings of the robo B are
powered by artificial muscles these are
made from peo electric actuators this
smart material basically contracts when
electricity is passed through it exactly
like a real muscle using these the robo
B can flap at an astounding 173 times
per second that's really nice Harvard
but still a touch behind the honeybee
with its 230 HZ Wings by the way if
you're wondering why it's so important
to increase that number the more flaps
per seconds the more stable it will be
in flight because on this scale gusts of
wind can easily carry the robot away the
robo be can also perch onto pretty much
any surface at almost any angle using
static electricity similar to when you
take the plastic film off a product and
it sticks to your hands incessantly and
after 2 minutes of trying to awkwardly
remove it you genuinely consider
chopping your limbs off because it would
just be easier however the robo be still
relies on an external teor for its power
and decision making and putting these on
board the robot at this scale is still a
long way off the har team did strap tiny
solar cells to the robo B to see if it
could generate its own power on the fly
from sunlight but its flight was using
up twice the power it could generate so
that's quite a deficit to
overcome each Robo B weighs just 259 mg
and in 2012 the Harvard team proudly
watched as it made its very first unted
flight however it lasted for the grand
total of 1 second before kening off
still it holds the record for the
lightest machine to ever sustain
self-powered
flight since Harvard's Beering work
there have been many other projects that
have popped up around the world but they
all face essentially the same problem
the required technology simply doesn't
exist yet computer chips although
remarkably small are still too big
especially those that are required to
run the advanced image recognition and
AI models on board for flower
recognition navigation and decision
making and then there's the batteries
we've been using the same lithium iron
technology in consumer tech for decades
now every industry is awaiting the
invention of a new lighter longer
lasting
battery realistically we're probably at
least a decade away from functional
robotic bees but they will come which
leads me to my next question should they
now personally I'm under the impression
that we should mess about with nature as
little as we can earlier I said that
Evolution has a 3.5 billion year head
start on us and who are we to think that
we know better about the delicate
balance of unfathomably complex
ecosystems we have no idea how the real
bees would react to robotic Mini Me
suddenly rocking up on their Flower
Patch it might scare them away they
might see them as Invaders and try to
attack them it could cause the bees to
become stressed and less productive Robo
bees could be too successful and the
technology could actually reduce the
need for organic pollinators causing
them to become extinct even quicker in
trying to solve the problem we could
make it
worse then there's the dystopian
elephant in the room I don't think I'm
alone in looking at these things and
instantly thinking terrorism I know that
might sound alarmist but what happens if
Rogue actors hack these robotic hives or
develop their own robotic bees that can
deliver a small payload of poison for
hyper targeted
assassinations yeah if we're not careful
we're going to find ourselves right in
the middle of a real life Black Mirror
episode of course it's not all negatives
there are benefits to an artificial be
over the real deal if the energy problem
is solved they would be more efficient
than real bees so they could work much
longer hours robots aren't affected by
disease they can survive in extreme
temperatures and they don't need to
hibernate the robots could also collect
data on the health of plants and small
shifts in environmental conditions that
might otherwise be missed essentially we
could use them to debug and optimize our
environment which is ironic because it's
debuging of another kind that is landing
Us in this mess in the first place on
the flip side there's also the rather
scary scenarios that could emerge from
Tiny robotic insects with the power of
mass surveillance and data collection
but I'll leave that to your
imagination I have to say with all
honesty it's it's really impressive what
the team at Harvard has achieved and
will likely go on to achieve but with
all of this in mind I'd like to propose
another solution to our dwindling be
problem now fair warning this might
sound a little out there but bear with
me because it could catch on why don't
we just save the
bees don't get me wrong I love
technology and I especially love when
Humanity puts our minds together to
create technology-led solutions to
social humanitarian or environmental
issues because sometimes it's the only
way out of a hot mess but it seems a
little bit odd to me that we're spending
millions and potentially billions on the
close to impossibly difficult task of
replicating a creature that has evolved
almost perfectly to keep our world
pollinated and if you take a look at the
history of human inventions we kind of
have a bad track record of bowsing it up
the first few times I mean in trying to
Perfect The Flying Machine we ended up
with the Hindenburg and then ryion a and
that's not a journey we want to emulate
again now I appreciate that not everyone
would agree with this but one could
argue that all this funding would be
better spent on further research into
why the bees are declining and remedial
Solutions I'm not saying it's as simple
as that because it really really isn't
but is it just me that thinks by instead
choosing to reinvent the bee wheel it
kind of feels like we're just giving up
I'm not trying to dismiss the
development of the technology in its
entirety though after all there are some
genuinely positive use cases that could
arise from it think robotic bees that
can be utilized for search and rescue
missions research and exploration in
dangerous or unreachable terrains micro
repairs on hard-to-reach parts of
buildings such as skyscrapers and Robo
bees could one day pollinate crops on
the International Space Station and
maybe inside a future Mars
colony so rather than coming across as a
lite all I'm trying to say is that most
people myself included love bees they're
beautiful creatures and I don't want to
live in a world where our Gardens
Meadows and forests are filled with the
sound of tiny mechanical
drones personally I'm more fond of the
approach taken by a team at Durham
University in the UK who've launched the
robo Royale project that aims to create
robotic bees not to pollinate but to
provide care specifically to care for
the real life queen of pre-existing
beehives of the 20 to 30,000 bees that
make up a single Hive the vast majority
are pollinators but then there's the
Queen's Court which consists of the
queen and her worker bees if she's in
good health and in good spirits she can
lay up to 200,000 eggs per year the
Queen's Health has a trickle down effect
on the rest of the hive affecting the
efficiency and total number of
pollinator bees the robo Royale project
aims not to replace bees but to create
artificial support bees powered by
Advanced AI they will live in the hive
acting as super worker bees directly
caring for the queen 24/7 such as
feeding and grooming her allowing The
Hive to reach its maximum
potential Robo Royale is in its very
early stages but it offers a much less
invasive approach to fixing the B
decline dilemma and I think if
implemented correctly it could be the
happy medium that bees and Humanity
needs with everything I've said in mind
it's very easy for me to stand here and
blame the ominous they for not doing
enough to save our black and yellow
Warriors but maybe we should all take it
upon ourselves to do our part by
planting more flowers selectively
rewilding parts of our Gardens and
communities and buying local honey to
support small scale beekeepers and who
knows maybe we'll discover that those
elusive robotic bees we've been and
chasing have been amongst us all along
thanks for watching just a quick word to
say that I couldn't make these videos
without the support of my patreon
members consider joining the exclusive
42 Discord Community by supporting me on
patreon it's a great place to discuss my
videos with like-minded individuals and
myself the Link's in the description but
if you don't want to or you can't join
my patreon then please don't worry a
simple like or comment to say thanks
would also put a huge smile on my face
thank you